being a hulk asks for balance
[Music]
it's easy
little punk
so i'm clearly nailing it at all these
things when am i ever going to use this
as a lawyer jen when you have powers
like this it's like putting a target on
your back in the backs of all the people
you care about oh cool yet another way
my life is grown thanks bruce all right
all i've been doing is showing you the
downsides of being a hulk but there are
a few upsides
our bodies metabolize alcohol at an
incredibly fast rate
which means
that we can drink so much and not get
drunk
all buzz no barf
this is good
jennifer walters is an attorney who has
accidentally taken in the hulk's blood
and has become like a chick hole a
she-hulk exactly
that's got a nice ring to it that name
better not stick
there's something so surreal and so
funny about a giant six foot seven hulk
in the courtroom
it was about putting a real human being
into these absurd situations
it's just like as cool and edgy as we
can get away with girl your ass looks
crazy right now it's something that you
think you knew which is law shows
and something that you think you know
which is marvel shows smash together
this show is so much fun it all has this
tongue-in-cheek self-referential thing
going on in the comics she broke the
fourth wall and was super meta
i just want to make sure that you don't
think this is one of those cameo every
week type of shows well except bruce
and blonsky
and
wong she spent all this time becoming a
lawyer and this idea of being a
superhero
is not appealing to her
being a superhero is a trial by fire
oh i'm not a superhero i just want to be
a normal anonymous lawyer there is no
going back to what you were before
who's gonna protect the world
if not people like you
this is expanding the definition of what
a marvel studios production can be
this is a radical revolutionary show can
we get some shots please it's an
emergency
you